hi today we're going to show you how to
connect GitHub co-pilot to an R Studio
project on posit Cloud the first thing
to do is create a new R Studio project
and when the project is loading we can
go ahead and give it a name maybe AI
coding
assistant and then as soon as the
project loads we're going to go ahead
and authenticate through
GitHub to do that you're going to click
tools on the navigation
bar then Global options scroll down to
co-pilot and you can enable GitHub
co-pilot first you're going to install
some packages in the
IDE and once this is ready you're going
to be able to sign in now to
GitHub so if you click on this button
it's going to give you a verification
code you can copy that and take it to a
GitHub
link paste in the verification code
click continue
authorize GitHub
co-pilot now you're done here you can
close this
tab and come back into the
ID this will update and it'll show you
that you are now logged in and ready to
use
co-pilot so we can open up a new script
to show it
off maybe I'll rename that ed.
R and we can start passing in you know
human language text right make a
function
uh that's going to calculate the area of
a
room you can click enter and you're
going to see the recommendation from
GitHub
co-pilot you can click tab to accept the
recommendation and you can run it and
now you have a function area in your
environment you can also ask it to say
you know I have a room of a certain size
find out the area of the floor and it's
going to know that it's going to take
the formula that I just defined and be
able to run this and find out that the
the area is in fact 80 for my size
room I can also use it like an
autocomplete so let's load in ggplot
2 and if I start typing the function
ggplot here you're going to see that
it's going to start filling it in for me
with some you know
recommendations okay let's just go ahead
and accept this and see what it comes up
with you know pretty basic first G plot
but then you can work with it again with
human language and say things like well
maybe I want to change the color of the
of the data
points we'll do that based on the
variable
class we can accept this and run it and
now we've got you know a slightly
improved graphic and you can keep
iterating on this using co-pilot to help
you out make new things and hopefully
make them
faster